we've talked quite a bit about the
vaccine but there's an incredible new
technology that Pfizer is developing
with the Pax lovid antiviral for covid
where does that stand
how does that work
and how are you able to develop it in
four months like you said and all of
that in just a few minutes
first of all what this is about this is
a real game changer
this is a course of treatment that you
get only if you get the disease you get
covered
then what happens is that you will take
for five days pills day and night
and twice a day for five days
and instead of 10 people from those that
are the easiest to go to hospital only
one will go
this is an end
with all the caveats that the numbers
are small no one died it was a hundred
percent efficacy on deaths of course I'm
sure that in real world when the numbers
are getting very high we may have 99
instead of 100 but uh
these are spectacular results for
something that you can take home and
stay home the biggest problem right now
in Europe in the US when you have shared
this every time that we have a search of
uh of covet it is that the icus are full
the hospitals are paralyzed they have to
postpone elective surgeries they have to
postpone other operations because they
don't have the capacity because of that
keeping people out of the hospital's
home keeping people
uh
without dying
it is something I didn't have before uh
and this is a significant significant
game changer